for decades video games have only grown
in popularity
back throughout the past year chances
are you maybe someone you know has
played games such as fortnite or
minecraft or
league of legends as recreational gaming
has really taken off so has the esports
industry where a select few
play for highly trained teams in leagues
bringing in millions and millions of
viewers and even more money
now some of these pro teams are based
right here in las vegas kate houston
takes a look at the rise in esports and
where it goes from here
i used to strive to play games and i was
always like a competitive person in
sports
and translated the gaming as well kyle
lander is team captain for dark zero
esports based in las vegas
with a team specializing in rainbow six
siege a popular tactical shooter game
freaking dark zero
basically just very dependent on
strategy lander and his teammates train
eight hours a day
six days a week whether it's setting up
a defense or setting up a tax we kind of
run it almost like a football team with
different plays
at the helm of dark zero is player
turned coach brandon
carr there's a lot of training that goes
into hand-eye coordination and reflexes
and anything with the advice in general
carr says the structure of an e-sports
team mirrors
any other athletic program while it may
be new to digest
it's serious and its popularity growing
over the next like 10 20 years you'll
see that entire
viewpoint shift because the people who
are giving those opinions are the people
who actually
grew up playing this over the past few
years dark zero has gone from a couple
thousand people watching to traveling
the world for invitationals
it will be the future eventually yeah
it's still
young but i mean it's the growth rate is
almost unimaginable while there is
massive growth the esports industry is
still new
so there's some unknowns for investors
here at the unlv blackfire innovation
hub they're using research to take away
that risk
dr robert rippy is the executive
director of the esports lab
we look at the environments that it
might operate in the business models
that it might function under and how it
integrates with
other components of the resort as well
ripy says las vegas is on the right
track
pointing to the hyperx esports arena so
the question then becomes
well what can you learn from that and
apply it
into the evolution of that they're now
looking into different venue sizes and
creating a more spectator friendly
environment
it's big and it draws a massive audience
so i think we have the opportunity
really to be at the forefront of that
and facilities like this and this is
where it can start
kate houston 8 news now well for those
who want to make esports their full-time
job we asked dark zero about that career
path while it's an exciting industry
they still recommend pursuing education
and having a backup plan the reason
being the lifespan of an esports career
typically short this is mainly due to
burnout from games and they say you need
to have a real passion and drive
in order to make it to the top denise
valdez observation they also have the
most comfortable chairs in the world you
see that yeah you got to step up our
chairs here